We got to discuss the debate in the old
fashioned one against that will be time
for you to ask questions to the panel
of the motion.
So the motion tonight is whether or not
the market is the best judge of good
art.
Now being an awkward,
I would say that I was.
I think we should find out what is art
market fellows now.
He sounds rather he supposedly worth
about 6 billion euros in the UK sales
alone every year,
although I don't know how much tax he
pays on that.
We have at least 10 outfits and the next
two weeks to thank for them as well as
the options.
There was a grumpy fellow audrick to
this week who claimed that it was absurd
in the middle of the banking crisis.
His paintings might sell for anywhere
between two and 9 million pounds,
but let's not forget where we are in the
house of one of this country's most
influential art collectors and taste
makers,
inventors,
et Cetera.
So part of the question is,
does the money work of our commands make
it better?
So to help us answer this question,
we have a very distinguished panel,
but I'd like to find out from you,
first of all,
before we get going,
quick show of hands,
who thinks that is the best judge of
good things?
Put your hands up now on two,
three,
four?
Yes.
Okay.
And who wouldn't?
Who wouldn't agree?
Come on.
Tell.
Satya said,
could you leave the building
and I think in order to try and convince
you otherwise,
we have a very esteemed.
I'd like to invite the first speaker up
please.